die frage nach dem wesen der zeit ist
eine frage die schon die
zb
den spätantiken theologen und
philosophen augustinus er fragt was ist
zeit und er sagt wenn ich es niemandem
sagen muss was zeit ist dann weiß ich
was ist wenn ich jemand erklären soll
was die zeit ist dann weiß ich es nicht
alle die frage was zeit ist ist eine
sehr zentrale frage
es gibt ganz verschiedene positionen der
zeit man kann ganz grundsätzlich
zwischen auffassung einer zeitgemäß eine
arie und einer bäckerei unterscheiden
was meint dass das ist eine
unterscheidung die der englische
philosoph mctaggart eingeführt hat die
arbeit der zeit meint dass wir zeit
subjektiv erleben dass es also eine
zukunft für uns gibt eine gegenwart eine
vergangenheit ist also eine subjektiv
erfahrbare zeit die b3 der zeit sagt das
ist kein subjekt derzeit erfahrung gibt
es und dass die zeit wie ein zeitstrahl
vor uns ausgebreitet liegt und es in
diesem zeitstrahl immer nur relation von
früher oder später gibt also wie sollen
große zeitleiste kann immer sagen was
war früher was man später aber die frage
nach der zukunft stellt sich nicht weil
die zeit vor uns gewissermaßen
ausgebreitet wie ein ganz langer zeit
strahl mit verschiedenen zeitepochen
drauf
es gibt wie gesagt den philosophen
- der eine ganz bedeutende zeit theorie
entwickelt hat augustinus vertritt er
seine auffassung der a3 derzeit für ihn
ist zeit immer etwas was mit zukunft
gegenwart und vergangenheit zu tun hat
augustinus sagt dann dass wir eigentlich
die gegenwart derzeit gar nicht richtig
bestimmen können weil wir uns versehen
ist die gegenwart schon vergangenheit
geworden die gegenwart kann eigentlich
gar nicht richtig existieren weil wenn
sie existieren würde müsste sie zeitlich
ausgedehnt zahlen wären sie zeitlich
ausgedehnt wäre würde sie in einen
zukunfts anteil und eine vergangenheits
anteil zerfallen und hätten wir wieder
keine gegenwart also augustinus
problematisiert sehr stark die gegenwart
derzeit wir haben dann andere
philosophen wie zb immanuel kant
immanuel kant vertritt die auffassung
dass zeit etwas ist was mit unserer
erkennenden subjektivität zu tun hat
kann sagt die zeit ist nicht etwas was
in der welt wirklich existiert
unabhängig von uns als erkenntnis
objekten sondern die zeit ist wie er
sagt eine reine anschauungs form ebenso
wie der raum eine reine anschauungs form
unseres ähnlichkeit ist das ist jetzt
ein sehr komplexer begriff kann will
damit nur sagen damit wir etwas erkennen
können müssen wir immer schon
voraussetzen dass es in raum und zeit
existiert und das ist in raum und zeit
existiert verdammt sich unseren formen
der sinnlichkeit raum und zeigen ein
anderer philosoph der eine wichtige die
halbzeit theorie entworfen hat ist
friedrich wilhelm joseph schelling
schelling versucht im gegensatz zu kant
der auf eine subjektiv
erkenntnistheoretische weise diese arai
derzeit in der b3 untergeordnet hat also
verdienen die besonders wichtig ist
gerade wieder die a3 besonders zu
betonen also sowas wie vergangenheit
gegenwart und zukunft wieder ins zentrum
der philosophischen betrachtung zu
rücken
schelling hat jetzt keine mechanistische
auffassung der zeit mehr also dass die
zeit einfach so verläuft auf uns zukommt
und dann in einem zeitstrahl die
vergangenheit über geht sondern zeit ist
wahrscheinlich etwas organisches zeit
ist wahrscheinlich etwas sinnvolles
etwas geschichtliches und wie ist der
begriff geschichte schon sagt bedeutet
für schöne geschichte nicht etwas
horizontales ausgebreitet wie ein
zeitstrahl sondern etwas was in
schichten auftritt also wir können in
der vergangenheit graben und gelangen
dann in tiefere schichten also schelling
hat ein ihr vertikales modell derzeit
und nicht sie ein horizontales modell
wie es die rede von einer zeitleiste von
einem zeitstrahl nahelegt ein weiteres
problem was noch generell angesprochen
werden muss ist dass wir dazu tendieren
die zeit zu verheimlichen
wir sagen etwas war zuvor oder danach
das sind natürlich alles begriffe die
wir aus der heimlichen redl entnommen
haben es ist also ganz schwierig über
die zeit so zu reden dass wir für ihre
beschreibung keine räumlichen begriffe
verwenden wie davor und danach
und das ist eine ganz große
herausforderung für die zeit philosophie
eine adäquate sprache zu entwickeln die
ihre realität gerecht wird